[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance I called for a federal grand
jury to be impaneled to determine if
crimes have been committed by the Trump
presidential campaign the Trump
presidential transition team and now the
Trump presidential administration
involving Russian attempts to influence
American democracy specifically the
presidential election of 2016 I call for
that grand jury to look specifically to
the actions of Trump attorney Michael
Cohen Trump business associate Felix
Sater Trump's former campaign manager
Paul Manafort and former national
security adviser Michael Flynn
specifically in regards to contacts with
agents of the Russian government in 2016
and 2017 I call on that grand jury to
hear evidence as to whether or not
indictment should be returned against
White House officials chief of staff
Reince Priebus or press secretary Sean
Spicer or others I call on that grand
jury to ascertain specifically whether
Priebus or others violating the 2009
Department of Justice procedure memo
requiring that White House contact with
the FBI about investigations be made
only by the president vice president
White House Counsel or principal deputy
white House Counsel is evidence of
prohibited criminal behavior such as
aiding and abetting conspiracy or
misprision of a felony I call on that
grand jury to determine whether
indictments should be returned against
house permanent Select Committee on
Intelligence Chairman Devin newness
Senate Select Committee on Intelligence
Chairman Richard Burr and officials at
the FBI and CIA I call on that grand
jury to ascertain specifically whether
newness and burr and the others
mishandled classified information about
investigations by the intelligence
services of the Trump Russian connection
when newness and burr had conversations
with reporters on behalf of the White
House I urge that grand jury to
carefully review the actions already
publicly acknowledged or reported such
as the contact between general Flynn and
the Russian ambassador Sergei kis lack
such as the meeting between ambassador
kis lyac and the president's son-in-law
such as the involvement of trump
attorney cohen and the four or five
different stories about that involvement
mr. cohen has told in
delivering a plan to general Flynn to
destabilize the government of Ukraine
such as the efforts by mr. Priebus to
influence FBI deputy director Andrew
McCabe and FBI director James Comey to
quote knock down
unquote the Trump Russia story by leaks
or announcements to the media I urge
that grand jury to ascertain if these
confessed actions already constitute
evidence of illegal actions by the Trump
campaign Trump transition team and Trump
administration and representatives of
the Russian government possibly rising
to the level of misprision conspiracy or
espionage and additionally to ascertain
if they already constitute an
overarching attempt to cover up these
actions and to obstruct justice
Trump's alleged involvement with Russia
obscures perhaps dictates every other
aspect of this existentially dangerous
presidency we have to have answers the
answer we should have gotten from Trump
and his gang was simple it should have
been we have done nothing wrong we will
give the FBI full licence to interview
anybody and read anything we have the
answer we have gotten from them was
instead Trump telling us he quote hasn't
called Russia in 10 years and to get on
with our lives and branding as sore
losers those who believe he is either a
Russian operative or has been
compromised by Russian intelligence and
by declaring war on the FBI and on news
organizations who publish stories about
this topic using leaks from anonymous
sources while we now have mr. Priebus
trying to get the FBI and other
intelligence community figures and
elected officials like congressman
newness and Senator Burke to act as
leakers to news organizations to get the
news organizations to publish favorable
stories about this topic the answer we
should have gotten from newness in his
role as chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee with access to
classified intelligence and burr in his
role as chairman of the Senate
Intelligence Committee with access to
classified intelligence was simple we
will immediately begin open and full
investigations preferably a select joint
committee to determine to what degree
Donald Trump knew of or Cole
with the Russian government to influence
the last presidential election the
answer that we instead have gotten from
mr. newness was that there is no
evidence of Russian contacts but quote
major crimes were committed by those who
leaked about Russian contacts which is
an impossibility if there were no
contacts the answer that we have instead
gotten from mr. newness and mr. burr
constitutes the two of them violating
their oaths of office and compromising
their personal ethics and the codes of
honor required of every public service
in this nation and completely
compromising any congressional
investigation they began to actively
serve as press agents to try to
influence media coverage in order to
suppress investigation and to suppress
truth and to suppress our ability to
know if our foreign policy if our
domestic policy in our school policy of
our self-defense policy if our
government is being run by Americans or
is being run by Russians we have to have
answers in short
senator Burr representative newness mr.
Priebus mr. manapouri director Pompeo
director Comey director McCain mr. Cohen
mr. Seder general Flynn mr. Kushner mr.
Trump we need to know from you if we are
still Americans or if we are now merely
living in a colony of Russia tell it to
the grand jury resist peace